[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome and
thank you for coming I know it's always
a terrific choice coming to an afternoon
session compared to maybe all the other
things you could do like take a nap or
something so thank you so much for
showing up my name is Karthik we have
two co-presenters with me
so please welcome Vidya she's a fellow
p.m. on my team and then we have Daniel
who is a valued Google cloud customer
and he's going to share a really
powerful story of how we use cloud
identity to help meet the organization
goals they'll be on a little later in
the talk we have three sections in this
in this talk first is cloud identity and
overview what is our motivation for
building this product why should Google
even care and why did Google enter the
space so you want to give you an
overview on that I'll do that second
we'll follow this up with Daniel and
he'll share the story of how they've
been using cloud identity to meet the
organizational goals so you can hear
directly from a customer and last but
not the least we'll have Vidya come on
and she'll be sharing new announcements
and also be doing some really cool demos
so we hope you'll love it we hope you
enjoy the session very quickly
I'd love a quick show of hands please
how many of you have heard about Google
cloud identity can you just show me your
hands
that's awesome this is already a great
session thank you that is really great
to hear that you've heard about it just
a follow-up question how many of you
have heard about beyond Corp okay still
a pretty good number so we will talk
about all of this as we drive into why
we talked about cloud identity why did
we launch this so a couple of things
that I have been happening unless you've
been living and living under a rock you
know this that organizations are
changing because their users are
changing the user expectations are
changing as people are bringing in
mobile devices into work as they're
getting familiar and loving cloud-based
services they're expecting the same
experience at work and that's putting
new pressure on IT and organizations in
general to make those users happy and
give them the way of work which matches
how they work in the
consumer world and you know this is not
going to go down anytime soon if
anything organizations are increasingly
telling us that they are going to go all
in on the cloud the amount of cloud
service is the number of cloud services
that they're going to be using is only
going up and you know three or four
years ago people who are worried about
laws and compliance and governance and
there was genuinely a question of is
cloud more of a hype or and will cloud
really happen now that's no longer the
case
customers are clearly saying that they
are going to move to the cloud the
question is when and how do they
actually do that so cloud is very real
and then we have data that shows that
this is from Gartner which says that by
2021 more than 50% of organization's 11
all in cloud strategies so really an
easier way of saying this is more cloud
and majority cloud is happening so
here's users saying give me more cloud
and organizations are said are saying
yes we are ready to embrace more cloud
and then the other things happening from
an infrastructure standpoint let me just
outline that for you
you've heard about containers today and
generally what it takes to build a cloud
service today is just getting
increasingly simple people are becoming
really comfortable at microservices
containers are taking off and kubernetes
in particular is very very popular we
have some data that shows that excuse me
40% of organize a 40% growth with just
the kubernetes deployment in an
organization and if you look at what
rules shared earlier today that number
is even higher if you think about just
awareness and willing to adopt
kubernetes so all this is saying that
users want more cloud organizations are
ready to move to the cloud application
architectures are making it easy to move
to the cloud so with all of this
happening there's a new thing that's
happening that organizations are
struggling with organizations
historically last 20 years have been in
this world where they are on this
corporate network is their assume trust
they believe that being on the corporate
network is how you get secure that made
sense but it made sense because your
applications were behind the firewall
your data was behind the firewall so it
made sense to protect that and that's
how organizations and there
protectors were set up fundamentally
what's happening with the cloud as you
all know the applications are in the
cloud more importantly the data that is
associated with those applications are
also now in the cloud so what are you
protecting that's behind the parameter
there's not too much and if this trend
continues everything is in the cloud so
the whole idea that you're trying to
protect something which is a corporate
network making trust decisions and
access decisions based of this access
parameter is no longer valid and
applications and the cloud and then
besides the data who are you
collaborating with it's an increasingly
collaborative world an increasingly
interconnected world so you're not just
working with your fellow employees that
may be distributed at other sites you're
working with partners you're working
with your customers and you're working
with other vendors who are not going to
get on your corporate network so this
whole idea of being on a corporate
network and that meaning anything is
completely moved as organizations move
to the cloud so last but not the least
we now have IT working on a bolt-on
strategy which is hey the old way of
connecting to the secure thing was using
something like a VPN that may or may not
always work it was complex if you forgot
your RSA SecurID somewhere and you just
couldn't get your work done until you
got back to a spot that actually had
that so these these are problematic and
you cannot have an architecture and an
access model that is a bolt-on you
cannot have cloud access models built
around how you architected and delivered
solutions to your end-users in a
predominantly on-premises based world so
that is the key insight for us where we
started to think about if the parameter
is no longer the corporate network and
users are looking for an access model
that's easy simple consumer like then
how do we build a solution from the
ground up that gives you really the Holy
Grail the idea that you can deliver
usability that is consume alike at the
same time you can give advance security
that gives peace of mind to
organizations so for that we built a new
solution from the ground up architected
for the cloud you really cannot take an
on-premise solution and bolt this on so
in fact we were privileged that we were
able to build a cloud based solution
from the ground up there are three key
themes that led to how we built our
solution and we'll get into
in a little bit but the first thing is
really about security we recognize that
we can talk about innovation all day but
if you don't have a secure foundation no
organization is gonna touch it so we
have to make sure this thing is
fundamentally secure from the ground up
and that's a key theme for us second
there is so much going on in the cloud
that you cannot rely on an access model
you cannot rely on static react reactive
policies we really believe that the
world has to be about smarts where we
can combine admin intent the admin
always has to be in control but we need
to proactively protect the users with
data that things like companies like
Google can provide so quick example
right Google is really good at crawling
the web and we know what the good
websites are and that's what we give you
when you do a search result when you run
a search query but we are also equally
good at crawling what we know are fishy
bad websites and we make sure that the
users never get to those that's not a
reactive policy that you need to set
that's something that we can proactively
protect for you in fact later on in our
context-aware demos that Vidya will have
will give you a glimmer of what this
could be and this you will be something
that you'll see as a roll out
increasingly in the quarters ahead last
but not the least we had to make sure
that this thing is really simple sorry
this thing is really simple people have
told us that as they put these solutions
together they really struggle with the
complexity they deal with multiple
vendors coming in there's white papers
that they got to put together and
there's never really that peace of mind
that tells you that I got my solution
right they're worried if they've paid
too much for their software they're
worried if they got too much software
going on and more importantly they
wonder if they actually got it right so
one of the things that we really focus
on is simplicity and simplicity is in
the end user experience simplicity in
the admin experience so we give you a
single unified UI sorry there's a timer
built in a single unified UI that means
you can manage everything from people
applications and devices all from one
console and last but not the least we
have a very simple SKU model we have a
free SKU and we have one premium or paid
SKU you get one license and that's one
price and you never have to worry about
that price ever
as we deliver additional functionality
so the simplicity all the way through
from the product experience to the
product licensing so let's dive into
very quickly what is cloud identity it
is what we call a cloud-based solution a
single unified solution to manage people
applications and devices so this means
not just your employees but also your
customers and partners it also means
your applications everything from
cloud-based applications to other
applications you may be using in your
organization and finally devices we
today support iOS and Android as well as
Chrome but in the future we will be
supporting the other desktop platforms
as well all available through one
unified console and product experience
last but not the least this is something
that we introduced recently but it is
not new for years what we did was we
were bundling cloud identity inside G
suite and we were using that to also
serve DCP customers what we were really
trying to do was is this something that
is resonating with customers is this
something that we should find out if he
should launch as a standalone entity in
the market and the overwhelming feedback
feedback from our customers was yes
please do we have all kinds of users who
are not knowledge workers who do not
need collaboration software who may not
always need all the access to all the
apps on GCP but they absolutely need
user and device management and over time
we may be rolling them onto GCP apps and
things like that so that's one of the
key pieces that came for us was the
feedback was strong with our existing
customers so we really took that out and
we made sure that from a pricing
packaging standpoint this was available
standalone which is really what we've
delivered here so it's available
standalone but it's not new it's been
battle tested in fact we have thousands
of customers and millions of users and
devices and the management because we've
been rolling this as far at issue okay
very quickly what is in a cloud identity
and what is we called the single thinner
glass a unified UI you will get all the
typical use cases that you would expect
from a cloud-based identity as a service
solution as well as a unified endpoint
or enterprise mobility solution so
specifically we have user lifecycle
management so everything from a user
onboarding user off-boarding when an
employee gets hired as well as fired or
changes jobs and things like that
everything's covered there
always are worried about account
security and I'll get into that in more
detail but we can protect your user not
just from a user name/password
perspective but additional multi-factor
autumn's that you need people want
single sign-on they want automated
provisioning of their user accounts what
we call SAP provisioning we have that
and we have iOS and Android management
along with all the other fount of
fundamentals like an admin console
reporting API is all of that so what
I'll do next is just go get into
specifically why Google and then we'll
dive into each of those big pillar
product areas so this is key for us and
this is at least how we believe in how
we look at the market when we started to
work on cloud-based identity and
cloud-based identity solutions there's
always this classic problem can we
actually deliver a user solution that's
simple and can we actually make it
secure so can we give advanced access to
users while preserving the advanced
securely their admins need and so that
was really key for us and as part of
beyond Karpin but they will walk through
that that's something we battle-tested
within Google I've joined Google two
years ago I set my password on my first
day at orientation I have never changed
my password I've in my two years I've
been here I've never typed my RSA
security secur ID key because I don't
have one I just use secure security keys
and so I was marveled at the way I used
to work and I felt like this is
fantastic and coming from an enterprise
background with that's really what we
wanted to enable for everyone we did
that through security we did that
through by being really smart like I
said earlier we think that ml data is
really going to come in and protect
people proactively the heritage that we
have we have seven services that are a
billion plus 30-day active count which
means we have tons of data about what's
what is good and what is bad and we can
use that to set policies in fact that'll
be part of the demo and I already talked
about the simplicity so let's dive into
the key pillars the first thing is user
management everybody knows that if your
user is compromised and somebody can
impersonate that user and get access to
really sensitive data so people are
looking for hey I need more than
password-based authentication they needs
two step authentication and I'll talk
about security key
in the next slide but we give you
whatever works for you from a two factor
out the perspective as well as the
security key piece that I'll just talk
about next but ultimately we know that
from our security keys and from a user
account standpoint there's tons of data
out there which says that for example by
Google's own internal estimate we think
there are more than one point nine
billion usernames and passwords floating
around in the dark web
this means that that password that your
employee is setting is likely already
compromised so it doesn't mean that you
can rely on passwords alone to protect
them you need this additional factor of
authentication so let's look at what we
did with security keys but if you like
your one-time use pass codes and you
like push notifications while we don't
think they are as secure we want to give
you that choice because that ultimately
you may have a business reason while
you're rolling that out okay so let's
talk about account security a bit
prabhakar talked about this a little bit
this morning in the keynote but since we
rolled out security keys for all the
Googlers we've had zero instances of
their accounts being compromised and
Google because I go back to our consumer
heritage we don't directly use that here
but we are able to use the data in a way
that protects organizations because we
can now come in we have we've looked at
we are constantly trying to get attacked
and hacked which means that we know and
can detect what an attack looks like and
we can apply the same practices in
proactively supporting and protecting
your users and for your organization
so that's account security lets keep
your users really secure the next thing
that we talked about is device
management a lot of times when people
think identity they think about user
identity right so Karthik is an employee
with employee ID one two three four
that's no longer super interesting that
is important but it's not the only thing
we look at things that are about me as a
user but I also look about at think
about additional context that might be
happening so as an example Who am I what
kind of role do I have in this
organization
what kind of privileges do I have what
kind of devices am I using to access
these applications all of that goes into
the attributes of making a really smart
decision about should I get access how
long should I get access things like
that
all of that happens if you can bring
device management into the
so we offer the same EMM capabilities to
manage ios and android that you might be
using in your organization already and
very soon as a roadmap feature we will
have windows and mac management as well
so that's device management because we
look at the device signals as well to
additionally protect the users and
protect the accounts okay so one of the
things they're probably not very well
known and this goes back to us bundling
cloud identity as part of G suite is
that we've been actively used by
organizations and Gartner in particular
recognized to us and this is not a
Gartner vote
this is customers coming out and voting
for our identity solution our device
management solution as a customer
favorite so you have to get a particular
rating and once you go about that that's
when you get this that's when you get
the badge and this is something we just
earned in 2018 so it's a customer choice
for our MDM solution we are more than 10
million devices that are under 30
reactive management okay so let's talk
about application management we have a
rich catalog of applications people need
single sign-on they don't want to come
in and configure those applications for
single sign-on and they're error-prone
so we just give you a pre-configured
catalog out-of-the-box
we support sam'l and OID C today and we
will soon be launching password vaulting
which is your password base SSO so if
you have a non-standard application that
doesn't support the existing standards
then we and they just use passwords we
can give you a single sign-on for that
okay one last thing on application
management we have a lot of apps and a
management another quick show of hands
how many of you have heard about cloud
identity aware proxy okay not as many
people in the room but this is a great
way for organizations to modernize their
applications or even lift and shift
their applications if you run them on
GCP you and then you have an identity
aware proxy what it does is it looks at
your identity again user state your
device state an additional context and
it can make decisions about your
applications we call these beyond Corp
for your second party applications so
the idea that you can take your modern
applications lift and shift applications
run them on GCP and then give them the
same protection
as any of the other applications happens
through identity aware proxy so when you
sign up for cloud identity this is an
option you can always use that if you're
looking at modernizing your applications
okay with that let me introduce Daniel
he's an amazing customer for us he has a
foundationally amazing story of how he
used a small group of employees on his
team to manage a very large employee
organization purely using cloud identity
so let me invite Daniel and he will tell
you more welcome Daniel my name is
Daniel Rani I'm the vice president of IT
at health channels I've been with the
company about six years and in that time
I've guided them through implementing
multiple cloud products first of which
was G suite but before I get started I
want to talk a little bit about our
company health channels was established
14 years ago as scribe America and has
since grown to incorporate three
distinct organizations that provide
services to over 2,600 locations and
employ 17,000 employees internationally
our primary line of business describes
an describe to somebody that follows a
physician around and assist them with
their clinical documentation some of the
biggest challenges we faced within our
organization when enabling our digital
workplace was we're a high-growth
organization to give you an idea in 2014
we had approximately 5,000 employees
today we have 17,000 we also experienced
a significant amount of turnover within
our organization we hire predominantly
pre-med students that are looking to
move on into medical careers they last
with us about two years we also have a
stringent training process that not
everybody gets through all of that
amounts to a turnover of about thousand
people every month
OOP all right lastly we run a very small
IT group total headcount is about six
people
and we do that and we have to administer
multiple application list of
applications as we adopt it more and
more cloud applications so how did we
deal with all of that so we dealt with
that by leveraging workdays reports as a
service and Google cloud cloud
identities API is to automate our
on-boarding and off-boarding processes
thus eliminating the need for IT to get
involved provision accounts we also
leverage Google's automatic provisioning
into third-party applications and
de-provisioning as well which also
removed the need for us to provision our
users into those applications giving in
them the tools they need from day one
lastly we simplified our login process
by enabling all the all of our
applications through the G suite SSO and
it enabled multi-factor within our
organization securing not only G suite
and our applications but our third-party
applications requiring em afraid to get
into those as well so why do we pick the
Google stack right or Google Cloud
Identity number one was the familiarity
of the product number one was a familiar
DDI with the product alright if it stays
it doesn't was the familiarity of the
product to our end-users and our
employees right they're used to using G
suite from higher education and in their
personal lives as well the other part of
it was familiarity of our admins right
they used G suite they've been using G
suite for the past six years so
leveraging cloud identity was a natural
progression
okay finally or additionally we also use
all right
additionally Google's focus on
simplicity and security really made it
easy for us to adopt multi-factor within
our organization right
so by that Google provides push
notifications to their peoples Android
app or to through Gmail as well as
security keys which make it really easy
to get through that multi-factor portion
of it originally there's simplicity and
security from an admin perspective as
well right when a user is on-boarded
into the app into cloud identity you can
set a period of time in which they have
to set up multi-factor and with it once
they log in they are prompted to go
through the multi-factor setup and their
setting they're ready to go with
multi-factor so that it decrease the
level of support that IT needed to
provide lastly Google's extensible api's
and the reliability really allowed us to
automate and move things forward without
any hindrances we did all of that within
a couple of weeks so looking forward
we're looking to further automate our
employee lifecycle and implement more
smarts which video will talk about a
little bit later as well as implement
device management and cloud identity for
external consultants all that said I'd
like to pass the baton to Vidya
talk about new
thanks Danielle hi everyone i'm vidya
and I'm one of the product leads on
cloud identity so we have been working
quite hard as a team to solve many of
the access control problems that our
customers are seeing along the
foundational principles of being smart
being secure and being simple so there
are a few exciting features that are in
the horizon that I'd like to now talk
about so first how many of you I think
spoke about you know about what Beyond
corpus ok great so Beyond Corp is an
enterprise security model that Google
was a pioneer of it was envisioned
within Google in the year 2011 because
of the motivation of increasing
simplicity usability as well as security
so that every employee at Google can
work from untrusted networks in a very
secure manner without using and setting
up traditional VPN networks so with that
goal the beyond Corp security model
essentially moves access controls from
your network parameter to individual
users and devices so that every user can
work really securely from any location
so in this new world
and with this new beyond core paradigm
cloud identity helps bring beyond Corp
to our customers in this world user
device and context is the new security
parameter Google is very uniquely
positioned in that we can protect our
customers with ML data across over 7
services with over 1 billion 30-day
active users so we have the context of
the user and the request namely which
device and what location it is
originating from that is used by the
rules engine to define and apply various
policies so that it can be used to
protect all the critical data and
applications whether whether it's across
your G suite apps and services or they
could be your internal apps that
built on GCP or using the identity of
our proxy or they could even be other
types of third-party applications
so now cloud identity helps meet every
organization's unique operational as
well as compliance requirements there
might be several scenarios that your
organization may want to support for
example you may have scenarios and
policies which determine the temporary
workers can access your work email only
from the corporate network you may
determine that full-time employees can
work from anywhere from any device
provided these devices have certain
security policies applied such as the
disk is encrypted or screen locks are
applied employees can access apps only
from company-issued devices or traveling
employees can access app from locations
cannot accept access apps from locations
which are deemed to have a high risk
profile and lastly some employees cannot
access apps outside regular business
hours I'll walk you through a quick demo
of one of these scenarios here and for
the rest of the scenarios here please
visit our security showcase at Moscone
South where a lot of these scenarios are
demonstrated in detail so now here's the
demo in the demo what I'll be walking
you through there is Mary who is a full
time employee
sorry Mary is a full time employee and
she is allowed to log into her work
email from the corporate network
however the corporation of the
organization has set policies that
determine that Mary cannot access her
work email or any of the gee suite
services from locations that are deemed
to have a high risk profile so let me
switch to my demo laptop here where I'll
kind of walk you through two specific
personas the first persona is okay
perfect
the first persona is that of an IT
administrator and here the IT
administrator actually go
and sets up these policies and the
second persona is that of Mary who is
now the user who is going to be
accessing the different applications and
G suite services from her machine so now
here I'm taken to a screen where as an
IT administrator I will first go and set
up an access level policy and I'll call
this access level policy to be of named
corporate network and I will define the
scarpered network policy to have a
condition which allows access to G suite
services or maybe any other application
only from a set of specified IP
sub-network so I create the condition
and I'm specifying a set of IP sub
networks that are allowed and that are
in the range now once that's done and I
save it I can now see a list of all the
different access level policies that
have been configured to support the
different scenarios that I had called
out earlier so now once this is done I
can go into the cloud identity admin
console and from here I can go into the
security section in the security section
I click on the section which says
context-aware access once I click on
context of our access I can actually
select the access level policy called
corporate network
that I had previously defined and I
apply it to the root organizational unit
so that all the users in my organization
can actually be allowed to access all
the services in this case the G suite
services only from those specified IP
sub networks and I can take this further
and I can say that I only want specific
users or specific organization units to
only access specific services maybe they
can only access Gmail from those set of
IP ranges so now once this is done it
has been configured I will actually now
go and log in as Mary from an incognito
window so I'm going to be locking into
gmail.com and I think I'm gonna be
logging in to my domain as Mary
and here you go as you can see Mary's
trying to access her work email from
this untrusted Network at this event
conference and she is denied access on
the other hand Mary is I'm as Mary
trying to access news kugel calm because
I want to see what's going on and I can
access the website so this is the first
demo and as you can see with access
level policies you can have a lot of
flexibility to meet your organizational
unique requirements and compliance needs
to do what you want and as you want to
see more of these demos please visit our
security showcase at the at Moscone
South and you can see this I'm now going
to move on to the next piece of feature
that we are going to talk about
okay so kubernetes so I think in this
morning's keynote you heard ORS talk a
lot about how enterprises are now
starting to move towards adopting a
micro services architecture containers
are growing over 70% of enterprises are
using cue ladies and so on so with cloud
identity we are aiming and striving to
provide IT administrators with a single
pane of glass to manage your users
devices and applications and we're also
looking towards extending this paradigm
to support containers and kubernetes
so I'm going to be walking you through a
demo here and consider a journey in
which an organization as far as your
cloud transformation is actually
container izing their applications and
is using cuban ADIZ to orchestrate and
deploy these applications now being an
enterprise they're probably looking at
using a hybrid environment that spans
multiple clusters across multiple clouds
their developer teams are building
applications and these applications are
being deployed in shared clusters and
they're creating their own namespaces so
now all of a sudden you have islands of
namespaces that have sprung up and there
are cropping up across the organization
with very limited governance and control
so in this particular demo that I'm
going to be walking you through I'll be
going over to personas the first persona
is that of an IT administrator who is
also a cluster admin who specifies
policies that govern who can do what is
part of policy management for these
dusters and the second persona is that
of a cluster user who is also a
developer who is allowed and authorized
to actually run and deploy applications
on these clusters so now let me take you
back to my demo machine and I will show
you what this looks like okay so let's
start here so this is the cloud identity
admin console from which you have a
unified holistic single pane of glass
view for managing all my people all my
devices and all my applications I click
on the cube release card here that also
now allows me to manage my Cuban IDs and
accumulate these deployments so I'm
taken to a view such as this where I can
now see a list of all my clusters that
are provisioned and running I can get to
see a list of all the different
namespaces that have been created across
my prod as well as my test environments
and I can also see a list of the
different policies that have been
created in particular there is a
resource quota policy that has been
created and enforced across my test and
prod namespaces in particular for
example there is resource code a policy
that has been set up and defined such
that my test names all my test
namespaces cannot use or request more
than 100 core of CPU and 20 gigabytes of
RAM and now I go to my roles view and I
get to see a list of the different role
binding objects that have been created
so here in particular there has been a
role binding object that has been
assigned to the user victor who is a
cluster user and she is now allowed and
authorized to run her jobs on all the
different tests namespaces so now I'm
gonna actually take you through the
experience as the cluster user visitor
so that she can
actually go and actually run this job so
let's see what happens here so I'm gonna
reconnect and first as the cluster you
serve it stir I am going to run the job
by trying to create a pod within the
production namespace so let's see if
that works so now I am going to try to
run the job in the production namespace
prod next and you can see that let me
try it again
and you can see that it will error out
saying that I do not have the permission
or the credentials to do so now I'm
going to try to create a pod in the test
namespace but I'm going to request more
resources than what has been allocated
for me by the policy administrator
earlier in the cloud identity admin
console so I am going to now ask for
creating a pod in the test namespace but
asking for more resources so I do that
and here you can see that the job fails
and it does so because it clearly sees
that I'm asking for more resources than
what was allocated to me and now I'm
going to try to create a pod in the test
namespace but asking for resources that
are well within what was allocated to me
so I do this and as I can see I'm going
to actually create it in the test
namespace within the limits within the
resource code are allocated and it is
going to be a success so yeah it's been
created and now as you can see with this
is an early preview and with cloud
identity you get a centralized single
pane of glass view for managing your
people devices and applications but you
can also extend and see how cloud
identity helps bring both policy and
identity governance for your
enterprise's container and kubernetes
deployments so
I'm going to now wrap this up by going
to the takeover slice summary slide okay
perfect okay so in a nutshell here are a
few key takeaways from our session today
cloud identity is absolutely critical
and central to creating a digital
workspace it helps you manage your
mobile devices it protects your users
and provides account security it meets
your organization's in your cloud
journey by integrating with various
on-premise systems its innovative and
transformational especially looking at
technologies like machine learning and
Cuban IDs and all of this comes with a
very simple subscription in a licensing
model and we have a promotional price of
four dollars per user per month so as
next steps please visit clout or go go
comm slash identity we have a 14 day
trial try the product and check it out
for yourself and also please stop by the
security showcase at Moscone cells and
there are a bunch of great demos
happening there we'd love to hear from
you so and for those folks we do have
some exciting giveaways today we should
have mentioned that earlier in the
session and we'd love some noise and for
those of you who are interested please
stop by we'd love to give you some some
giveaways
you
[Music]